I basically don't trust anything in
reality not Authority not my mind I just
trust data and numbers and the only
thing I believe in is I don't want to
die Brian Johnson is a successful
entrepreneur who has spent every minute
of the last 3 years not just slowing the
aging process but actually reversing it
what if I tried to become the best in
history at not dying project blueprint
involves a large team of medical experts
cost him $2 million annually and
reliably provokes the ire and suspicion
of others I'm usually the most
unrelatable person at the table uh so
like we think we have choice we think we
have optionality we don't do you believe
that there's a possibility that you
won't
die
yes